director of the Institute which is the
sponsor of this together with colleagues
in the school journalism and question
without the Weizmann Institute involved
in this i think in time scarce resources
is worth responding to that my lord who
supports us and the idea is that it were
very much interested in global the
japanese and how they change and read I
presenter interested in how America the
exercise its cultural hegemony and
framework of the European Institute
taking the step show that we've been
very very interested in how these kinds
of powers are exercised across the
Atlantic unit or would you be how Europe
itself that operates globally how that
all these operations per second the
American so Pavel we have tonight and
organized
I colleague Catherine Brown is ending is
a step toward giving this our best
effort organizing a series that is
bringing together in case they call it
historians also cultural policy of our
California with historians but also
ministration so with that Catherine on
the interviews you ever teaches here is
also getting your degree I had school
for a very distinguished guest has got
the media's past current enrollment
state-sponsored broadcasting and first
our speaker people call his professor of
diplomacy and director of master's
program in public diplomacy at
university of southern california he
previously was a lecturer in american
history at the university of birmingham
and professor of American history of the
mercy light caster he's authored several
books at least for discussions day when
which include the Cold War and united
states information agency Americans ha
pagana embassy and I'm projecting Empire
and girls and popular cinema and the
forthcoming book projecting tomorrow's
science agenda popular sentiment no
that's how the sound in February that's
I didn't relate this most people didn't
wanna know what happened during thank
you robocop so I think it's starting a
sighting you're welcome professor
Collins and next Tyra Hannah David
Edinburgh is director voice of america
and there he oversees a worldwide
operation of broadcast 43 languages
through radio television robot and the
internet and most recently he served as
a director of communications from public
diplomacy at the American Embassy in
Kabul Afghanistan and is also having sex
with career in journalism and
communications from 1975 1980 reported
for National Public Radio where you
cover the White House Foreign Policy
defenseless years and then connecting to
the 1998 use a television correspondent
for ABC News and 98 2006 suica CNN's
chief 45 and jasmine tea bunny who is a
los angeles-based correspondent for the
british broadcasting corporation
characterforge variety of DC news
platforms including ABC world news BBC
World News America and BBC radio and for
moving to California he was Washington
correspondent the BBC and finally
emmanuel st. Martin who has been in
europe correspondent for best 24 before
that was a print journalist weekly the
points and he's also the author of
several books including the art French
arrogance
about French foreign policy an
exhausting founder french-speaking
magazine called French morning and Ron
have you all with us leading well first
year after all what I want to do to
begin with is to try and assets on to a
basic frame of reference explaining
where I see international broadcasting
and public diplomacy fitting together
and because we're a diverse group might
not be used to thinking about public
diplomacy as a as a finger tour so I'll
say something about what I think bother
to vertices and then I want to give you
a potted history of international
broadcasting before setting up something
of the new terrain on which
international broadcasting now operates
and then then the outlining some of the
responses of international broadcasting
to this terrain and I think the scene of
the responses and the challenges of the
new terrain will generate questions for
for the parable and my theme really is I
hope I can tease out as I go something
of the tension within public within
international broadcasting between the
policy needs of public diplomacy and the
ethical requirements of the practice of
journalism and I think one of the things
is really reason is really exciting
subject in Colombia is because of the
role of columbia journalism program as a
particularly the cumbia journalism
review as being a sort of a beacon of
good practice that grabbed a number of
moments EPOS history when they ran into
problems as problems we're in the
trailers review here so there's a
certain symbiosis so most of all what is
public diplomacy well if I mote
diplomacy like this and say well first
of all you've got to look what
traditional diplomacy isn't that as I
see simply an actor's attention to
national actors attempt to manage the
international environment but through
the process and engaging with a foreign
actor so the past it's been heads of
state meeting one other professional
diplomat in contact with professional
development government-to-government
communication public diplomacy is
different it's still trying to manage
the international environment but it has
a particular set of tools the tools of
engagement with a foreign public and
instead of the reason one of the major
ways in which a government could
communicate public is through
broadcasting so when
when government sponsors bone cancer
that is both form of international
broadcasting is a form of public
diplomacy the public diplomacy is a
relatively new term it forms the beam
emitted as today of being foreign policy
through engaging with the foreign public
only about 1965 but beneath that term we
have five practices that I see as being
pretty much as old as a steak raft and
to those five practices that are now
turn the first practice the first way in
which then international actor should
engage with a foreign public is by
listening to that public and ancient
philosophers of stay crafting a warlike
might Zuzu and others recommend but
listening recommend studying the people
you're trying to engage with the second
form is advocacy going out and
explaining yourself this is something
that was done in Asia Greece so it's not
a new form of diplomacy at all third
full cultural diplomacy facilitating
export of your publicist on people
Romans did Byzantines davison imager
sincera who was subsidized by
an emperor to spread all the docs
Christianity in what's now Eastern
Europe exchanges exchange the potency of
engaging foreign public by exchanging
with with that public that's also an
ancient thing part of farming practices
in Northern Europe and other places in
the world to and finally international
broadcasting this has been done through
chronic media but I would argue can be
mapped Fatima trace back to certain
previous practices of States seeking to
facilitate the spread of news rather
than opinion about their country to
their neighbors the United States cable
only nineteen sixty-five and imposed is
one in ten of public diplomacy on these
five practices the reason they imposing
town was because of your aqua see they
thought it'd be a good idea to pull
together to establish the authority of
the agency in the united states
information agency which existed at that
time to conduct public diplomacy but the
town is not necessarily a good thing
because the truth is in each of these
elements is quite distinct and does the
best if allowed a certain degree of
Independence in fact most countries have
pretty separate agencies to conduct each
of these functions serving now the
United States which thinks it's a great
idea to try a pole together and the
result is that often the five elements
try and put heart and as a historian
it's been great for me because I get to
write about all the terrible strain with
the people who were in
advocacy try and pull international
broadcasting in the line and try and get
them to you know project messages and
compromise on the news and so forth but
I think it's more than to live through
and counterproductive to the ends of
foreign policy but a lot of the history
of public diplomacy is a conflict
between these different elements
international broadcasting comes from a
number of quite different places there's
the desired of the nation-state to
project its image a long term concerning
the state you go back to people like the
Holy Roman Emperor Frederick the second
you would publish a newsletter around
1100 mainly about why he didn't like the
Pope that particular button this would
be translated supplied to the Royal
Courts all around Europe there's
interest in transmission of news always
important to new regimes you can see how
the Dutch regime william the silent
comes to power around 1600 pays a lot of
attention to getting a use of things
that are happening in the netherlands
out of their perspective is understood
and finally in the 20th century became
necessary for the old empires of Europe
to connect to their own citizens living
overseas so a number of the European
countries established
services the net reduction the way great
in elements broadcasts to its Dutch
citizens in the East Asia and this idea
of connecting to expats creates
international international broadcasting
finally have a transmission of of
culture using radio to spread cultural
ideas around the world elements in your
culture we go through a number of
distinct phases in the history of
international broadcasting it begins
with us a competitive national
projection different nations setting up
radio stations to impress their ideas
their perspective of the world Radio
Moscow in the early days was one of the
most prolific in World War two Britain
develops a new approach seeking to make
bounced news credible news into a virtue
and part of the communication brand if
you like of the country and Griffin he
becomes a mentor in the United States
enters world war two becomes mental to
American International broadcast in
assisting in the creation of voice of
america which adds its own spin will
only pledging himself to give bounds use
whether the news is good or bad but also
adding a cultural dimension so coming
from the beginning both a used
see you at the value would also a
cultural diversity value using making
great use of American music
international broadcast the Western
international broadcasting was
maintained Cold War and one of the
best-known stories is the way in which
the VOA broadcast with its kind of world
cup jazz music was immensely popular in
eastie arrow really across a forty-year
area but in the u.s. a new genre of
international broadcasting in marriage
not a national projection broadcasting
bubbles called surrogate broadcasting
and the idea of surrogate broadcasting
is that a concerned country would
establish a surrogate for a media
organization in the country wish to
engage with they will start it with
excellence and will seek to provide a
news programming of interest or
political value to that target country
key examples in creation radio of the
radio free europe where you had exiles
broadcasting in the languages of target
countries this is much much more
political in its origins The Voice of
America sorry be broadcast
originally by the CIA some of the people
who were the original broadcasters were
refugees have decidedly bludging
political backgrounds who were more
value politically that they were as
broadcasters but the great advantage for
the OA was that the Celia having its own
radio station to play with the away got
to evolve into the good cop and it
became possible the VOA to emulate what
it saw as the BBC's credibility values
though VPC few scrapes in its history
and so they always freezes you a charter
obligation to be balanced in its
presentation reviews that's been
incredibly important part of its history
the Western broadcasters played an
immense part in the 1980s as channels
for communicating for sustaining the
reform community for the community in
Eastern Europe figures are as high as
eighty percent of people to call this
new west of broadcasters we really
became part in flight and had I think
the immense impact of that political
change this is really the watermark of
the importance of
broadcasting but the problem was when
when the gold will came to an end what
is the role of international
broadcasting and all sorts of questions
are asked about it in the countries
which have been subsidizing
international busting the government's
say one of the questions was why do we
need Radio Free era when yer is free and
Egypt different stations had to address
these kinds of questions but
broadcasting began to change a number of
new features there was more emphasis on
Interactive's or phonons a new kind of
relationship audience and the new kinds
of broadcast mechanisms the station's
moved away or supplemented their
shortwave broadcasts we use of FM so
partnering with affiliates in countries
to which they wished for all cars so
that they could be Heather domestic
channels and from mid nineties you have
a use of online resources in various
ways we always one of the leads the way
in this initially
mindful programs that scream scripts
available what was the crippled go for
protocol I'm sure nobody probably not
many of you are old enough to actually
of youth go far as her as a web platform
that it was their actual wagons but you
know maybe the greatest challenge to
state international broadcasting now has
been the emergence of commercial
commercial based international
broadcasters like CNN moving in today
that space and you have required to be
government breathing too stupid and
space in the past and regional
broadcasters like Al Jazeera really
began to shake things I would have spend
some time now talking about the new
terrain and some of the features i see
it's not single person has to face now
first of all there are many many more
new players in marketplace I think just
we in this world you've wanted to could
put together an international
broadcasting program using the equipment
right here put it online probably be
will anybody want to listen to you know
how do you the question no longer is how
you get information in front of
international audience it's how do you
market that information so that people
will actually want to
pardon the barriers to entry in
international broadcasting are so much
lower than they once were and it's so
much easier to get material out a lot of
this is of course to do with new
technology that the new technology is
creating new directions of communication
that are a great challenge for
international broadcasting if the past
international broadcasting worked in
sort of a verb in a virtual sorry in a
vertical communication model where there
were a few great sense of communication
power well most significant in Moscow
and Washington and when these centers
spoke everybody around the world
listening after an information kind of
came directly down from the top to all
the people round bottom aboard with the
communication mountains waited to hear
what was being said communication
doesn't work that way anymore now we are
horizontally oriented and information is
passed from person to person to person
across the horizontal mendler the
international broadcasters have to
compete with many other sources of
information and have certain advantages
but they also face disadvantages too but
i think this horizontal horizontal
nature of the communication environment
the massive challenge one of the
challenges that comes out of this is
that it's now possible given the amazing
plurality of information sources in the
world which could include people like
you on facebook right it's not possible
for you to get all your information
people who are exactly like you so if
you are a 15 year old girl who likes
Justin Bieber it's possible for you to
only get information from other people
who are also 15 years old and also like
Justin Bieber and maybe that's not so
much of a problem if you have a closed
loop a 15 year olds who really like
Justin Bieber there can be a shock
revellers but they don't know as the
other week in Los Angeles when I was
standing next to a 15 year old girl
really like Justin Bieber and she was
completely shocked with our windows in
the space shuttle as it went by Michigan
no people went in the space shuttle it
was amazing that the rantings human
spaceflight somebody shouldn't watch
justin bieber into orbit but the problem
is multiplied when you say go go to that
are one of these closed loops of equal
overall co-religionists and ceases to be
funny when you think of a world where
it's possible to only later if make
other people who share a particular
idea or a particular religious extreme
position how do you break into those
niches where language issues community
issues religious leashes that's a great
challenge and all this has to be done
with less resource one of the great
features of international broadcasting
is it's getting harder and harder harder
for broadcasters to sell what they do to
their boundaries broadcasting an
excellent job of presenting itself as a
necessity of the Cold War but it's much
harder to sell itself in a post-cold war
environment unless you are obviously
connected to a project lightning war on
terror I think another problem is that
the role of international broadcasting
is misunderstood and maybe the role
public diplomacy is misunderstood the
people who fund it by and large are
looking for a magic bullet that they can
fire foreign policy problems they're not
looking to do something like say build
relationships they're not looking to
develop a two-way street or create a
something like it
standing or have a conversation or
certainly not to learn more about the
world it's all about the one wave
rejection and this is not the way the
communication works to that and if you
want to approach the world in terms of
imposing yourself on it you're not going
to get very far you have to approach it
from the point of view thinking that
engagement thinking about relationships
so this mismatch between what
broadcasters now do how communicators
now think and what senators and
congressmen expect I see is a big
problem so international broadcasting's
responses have been quite creative there
have been doing business models the BBC
and and France both responded by
creating but both responded to the
challenge of CNN by creating their own
television channels and initially France
used a state private model but I believe
that the private sector has been bought
out so to re-launch the state
unemployment whereas the BBC is able to
run as a BBC world as a commercial
operation without financial aid from the
British government as if with it without
tising which i think is as good as a
surprise that that was possible with it
but it certainly allows what he done
there are new stablemates for
international broadcasters in the United
States really happy international
broadcasting governor's under that
umbrella you have stations that have
much more overt political agenda of
Voice of America particularly regular
sawa was created in the place of the
Arabic in the early 2000s and ellora
America's taboo channel they came the
Middle East you have international
broadcasters moving in to development
work actually working with partners in
the world to build capacity example this
is the BBC World Service trust which has
sought to teach broadcasting techniques
to generate reliable search data or
media in the developing world I know the
away also get involved with developing
journalism in the places around the
world I think that this idea of building
capacity has been one of the functions
that its natural or classroom is a very
interesting development all the
broadcaster's that I know anything about
now placing immense emphasis on
partnership not seeing themselves as
being the sole providers who one-stop
shops rather the entities that can work
with other countries provide services
for and other broadcasters and this is
something that David's been by
developing at the LA and we see also a
new modes of consumption as
international broadcasting has to move
away from just because you don radio
sets to moving into handheld devices
internet services and being consumed in
the way when people won't necessarily
sit and listen to a long stream of a
project that might hear a part of the
program or email or sent in a small
reward or mashed way and the the key I
see here is the international
broadcasters having to learn to work as
a lot uncle in information brand and I
think it's like the transition from if
you imagine a supplier of water who used
to have everybody plumbed in and turn on
the tap
we go along pipework important we get
water from the tap like a water utility
maybe that's how things were originally
for the BBC of the OA or radio france
international and they would have their
audience now people are going online and
finding new stories and the most
numerous might be sourced from
international broadcasting sources in a
boa story BBC story or transferred for
story whether they read that story
whether they decide to pass it on to the
other people in their information
network and whether those people then
choose to pass it on could be based or
is based on the reputation the brand
associated with that story so if you see
a story that has a strong brand all
three of our speakers come from
organizations that have as program it
goes further so I think there's a
transition in terms of the wing users
past for moving beyond you have your tab
labeled a BBC World Service drink on it
to you go to a sort of information store
and you see a bottle label BBC and you
think well I'll drink that I'll pass it
on to somebody else and you leave on the
Shelf the bottle either no name or
labeled a CCTV nine or some broadcaster
that you have less less confidence in
but the question is how do you stay
relevant and I think the international
broadcasters how to ask this all the
time and to ask themselves
relevant to the audience how do they
stay relevant to the people who are
funding them and this is not an easy
question to answer and sometimes the
answer to those questions is a challenge
to the history of the particular
broadcaster and I think we can see how
international broadcasters often have to
make really difficult choices that bring
alternate commitments to particular
languages for example into question and
then demand the final point I wanted to
make citizens set up this picture is to
say that I think the future is very
unsure for international broadcasting
international broadcasting is immensely
relevant in some places in the world but
the governments are increasingly
skeptical as to why they should be
funding it in publix are skeptical
discover violation funding it and people
are living differently now one of the
issues that I haven't come out in
discussion is that there is a tremendous
mismatch between the language is start
between the locations of audiences and
the languages in which in turn
regards to speak fifty percent of the
BBC's audience in any one item which
will not be living in the country
associated with that we broadcast in
Houston for gas containing and what they
did that fifty percent of people
listening Hindi but not listening within
India and so on multiple this separation
of audience in foreign language from
particular geographical spaces poses all
sorts of problems anyway that's what I
wanted to say to set things up